the town of Indy actual in northern
India sprawls on the banks of the river
Ganges here stands one of the most
important temples in India it's the main
temple of the Vindhya vicinity a
powerful Hindu goddess thousands throng
to this shrine but this is more than a
house of worship within the bustling
temple down a dim corridor is a tiny
locked room out of bounds to all but a
tormented few it's called the cave of
spirits a home for the dead and last
hope for the possessed
in the holy waters of the Ganges a man
and his helpers prepare for an arduous
task
Lakshmi camp Shukla is an exorcist a
pursuer of spirits and today he'll take
on some formidable foes families have
traveled many miles from all over
northern India to seek his help I have
four five lumps in my neck I get dizzy
sometimes my eyes roll up my neck turns
stiff but their woes appear to begin in
strikingly similar ways usually at
twilight women walking down lonely road
since an eerie presence they feel
themselves under attack overnight
something takes possession of them some
blame gods of the earth and air others
point to spirits of the dead no one is
certain
well a lot of people here do say that
this is just superstitious those who
don't face this problem say it's
nonsense
those who suffer believe it's real Sally
kromm came with his 15 year old daughter
Moony for eight months Mooney has been
depressed and acting strangely she had a
stomach ache
her eyes got blood-red she starts
talking nonsense whatever comes into her
head
Sally kromm and his wife of try doctors
now as a last resort they'll attempt
exorcism
for Mooney and the other girls the
moment is at hand The Exorcist works
them into a trance one by one the girls
break down yep when the spirit comes
forth that a girl loses all control over
her body that's what I know she has been
possessed The Exorcist urges the spirit
to talk
it seems ready to surrender I will leave
her body will leave her forever the
spirit has agreed to leave but the
Exorcist must find it another home he
knows of only one place a place where he
can jail it for eternity the cave of
spirits but first he has to get Mooney
and the other young women and their
demons to the cave the dancing distracts
the spirits keeping them from bolting
the chamber doors are carefully opened
the spirit that possesses muni responds
with a spasm of rage then leaves the
girl's body the Smashing of a coconut
signals the rituals end Mooney will
leave but the spirit that tormented her
will remain here forever
two days later the Exorcist makes a
house call to check on muni for this
family the exorcist extreme treatment
seems to have worked and they now count
themselves believers in the world of
spirits